welcome back guys we're on episode 14 of
the demo rpg and for this episode we're
basically going to sort out a whole
bunch more tests and i've already done
most of the stuff offline as it took
some serious tweaking to make sure we
got everything right i also found a few
memory leaks in our code and we're going
to go over everything and as you can see
down here at the bottom left we've got
quite a few more
things worked out so some other things i
did that i also want to go over
is i've started taking these dot h files
and putting their actual the definitions
of the functions and stuff into
associated cpp files and this is going
to help reduce some potential header and
include order problems that i was
starting to have while writing the rest
of these tests so
currently i
you'll see here in this test class we
have we are fully testing all the
functionality of abilities all the
functionality of buffs
all the functionality of our core stats
including our operators basically
anything there's a function of
we test it out that's that's the main
thing
so that's the big thing you can do as
you're going through now i'm not going
to go through every little fine detail
but i want to at least explain
how these are working so let's just look
at this stats for example it's core
stats
i'm going to put it over here give it a
little room uh give it a little zoom
all right so as you can see we got a
default constructor so we test that
we've got a constructor that takes every
stat so we test that one
and we've got a constructor that takes a
single stat and sets them all to that so
we test that too we got a plus equals
operator we test that one
minus equals we test that one and how
you want to write the test exactly is up
to you but basically you just do the
operation and assert that it is what
it's supposed to be for example the
default stats plus stats a
should be all fives
and so on and so forth
and as we continue on there's the equals
it sets it equal to another one we test
that one out too it also
seems to work so now when you run the
stats it should all work and here's
where things started to get interesting
when writing these tests these items i
was making tests
for weapon items and for armor items and
for potions and just testing out all the
functionality and i came across some
interesting scenarios that i really had
to dive into and
well
let's analyze how this works here
so when you
create an item you have to use the item
manager and this
is somewhat breaks
a few rules i found out because if we
look at our items and we got items here
let's put it over here
we start out with an item delegate now i
went ahead and got rid of the get the
virtual void get type because we weren't
using it anyway so there was really no
use for it
but we did have uh we do have to make
something in here virtual
and now there's a tricky thing about
virtual functions about virtual classes
and i'll leave a link to some articles
down below on this there's some there's
some good ones
but basically
if you might be instantiating
an item delegate
with polymorphism
and you might delete delete it it needs
to be sure to delete
everything you know all the classes this
one and whatever it ended up being so
there's some interesting tricks to that
and basically
if you could polymorph this into
something else and then call delete on
it
you need to make sure you have a virtual
destructor and typically this is public
but we are making it protected
specifically because we're doing some
friend classing so normally they say if
you're doing a
pure virtual destructor you need to make
it public if it's protected then don't
make it virtual but we are making it
protected
because we have an item manager that is
handling all this stuff and we don't
want the end user deleting
items ever anyway
so it's a little bit of a different case
uh
compared to what i'm going to link down
below and what the standard is but i
think it works for our case so we are
breaking some rules in this series now
herb stutter would be angry with us all
right well
yeah we're doing some sort of strange
stuff with the friend class well because
this being protected and it being
deleted down an item later right here
and this could be potentially cast to
something else it isn't
in here but when we're messing with this
inside data sometimes we cast it to
armor sometimes we cast to a weapon
sometimes we cast it to a potion and
when it gets deleted that cast could
still be hanging out
now we don't ever delete that cast
but we might set whatever that cast is
to a null pointer because if we don't
say if we delete this item but we happen
to have a reference hanging around to
this item delegate as armor which i'll
explain more in a second that becomes a
dangling pointer
so we never want to call delete on this
from anywhere the only place that should
ever delete it is right here
and
for that reason we want this to be
protected because we don't want anyone
else to accidentally delete it if we
left it public like so then someone else
could delete it and we don't want that
to happen so that's why we're in a
special case where this is protected
that's probably not going to make sense
to anybody but as you start to wrap your
head around this stuff a little more it
will make more sense and this is great
practice for that sort of thing so i
hope you guys appreciate i'm taking the
time to try to
teach some of the more difficult aspects
so yeah smash the like button if you
don't mind and subscribe to the channel
to keep learning and to keep hanging out
with other coders and stuff we also have
a discord just throwing that out there
all right well i've done my
advertising as needed so we can continue
so we have
the item is allowed to access this and
it's specifically so that it can delete
this delegate here
yeah
and that's what's happening right here
if we don't have it as a friend then it
can't delete it as we'll see if i
comment this out hit save this gives a
little squiggly and says it can't access
it
there we go
and if we make this public like it's
supposed to be well it can access it but
so can everything else and that's not
how we want it because we have an item
manager that does all the stuff and we
don't want anyone else touching it
because this is you know we're going to
be moving
we're going to be doing interesting
stuff with this data equipping items
using potions and whatnot and we have to
carefully manage how these pointers are
are doing things and we got to use
pointers because we don't want to be
accidentally copying and allowing people
to dupe items we're not going to have a
broken system if we can happen not to uh
like most of the games out there
we're not trying to be shoddy developers
we're trying to be proper developers
over here
all right so that covers most of the
changes here
really it was mainly getting that sorted
out it took some research and figuring
out and figuring out that i had to
actually break the standard rule in this
case
which i didn't see a way to follow the
rule and do what we wanted to do so
it happens i guess you got to do things
against the grain sometimes and
i don't know what else to say about it
then i i just i just felt good breaking
the rules in a way that i thought made
sense there's something there's some
good feeling about that
that's hard to fully explain and i will
say that there's a chance that i could
be wrong and that there's a better way
to do this chances are there's well
let's be fair no matter what you do
there's always a better way to do it
unless
well you know not necessarily because if
you say hey there's a better way and
then you test the other way and you find
out it's less efficient or uses more
memory or something you know maybe i am
right i don't know i'm not really going
through the the full the full testing of
every option here i'm just doing
something that works and this works
pretty good for what we're doing
and it passes all the tests which we're
going to walk through here in a second
all right just looking through this and
making sure there's no other things i
did put a virtual protected destructor
here in equipment delegate as well not
sure if that's needed but also another
thing now that we have a pure virtual
destructor that's why we get rid of that
get type because we got to have at least
one thing pure virtual here so that this
detects that it's a pure virtual class
otherwise we're going to have other
errors so
that's yet another thing
and we don't want people to instantiate
either these
so no one can instantiate equipment
delegate because it's got a pure virtual
function and of course that's armor so
normally with pure virtual functions you
have to override them
and whatever is using it but with these
destructors that is not the case which
is really interesting because they are a
special case all other virtual functions
you do have to override in all the child
classes
i guess yeah
i think i said that right
but with these destructors you do not so
it's just a special case there they're
the only functions like that
other than that i think we're looking
pretty good here
we still got friend class item manager
and all these and that's as intended
yeah we could probably even yeah yeah
we're good
so i think that's enough on the items
i'm going to close that out for now and
we're going to just walk through some of
these tests and how they work now the
ones up above are pretty straightforward
they basically just test every
functionality of those but getting to
the weapons where's where i really had
to analyze what was happening here so i
think it's important to walk through it
all right let's walk through the item
or the weapon
so first of all because our backpack and
inventory systems they all want an item
you've got to instantiate
some sort of item
it can't be an armor or whatever so
that's the one we always want to be
instantiating and that's why we're not
allowed to even create anything else and
that's why we gotta use these special
functions because if we go to yeah
whatever in our items you know if we go
to our backpack it's only items and if
we go to our equip section it's all
items so the underlying memory is
carefully managed
i feel like i'm beating a dead horse at
this point let me know am i beating a
dead horse or is the horse still still
going but this is just really important
to understand all right so we create a
weapon all right i added a few new
functions but let's look at this create
weapon first and there's some other new
things here too
so the create weapons the same as before
it makes an item
instantiates the memory it returns a
pointer to it now this pointer that we
return is now under our management we
have to decide
what happens with it so it's important
to know that this data that it creates
in this pointer that it returns
we have to now manage
there's no one else that's going to
control this from here
so that's why later we'll delete it but
first of all let's just do some checks
we want to assert that the item's not
null
and i made some new functions just check
so people can check on the fly
if you have any given item you can check
is it a weapon is it armor is a potion
and just get a true or false back
on any of those functions so i went
ahead and made those little helper
functions here
here it is there's the his item a weapon
now all it does is it does a dynamic
cast of the data
and if this succeeds then it's true
otherwise false so this pointer is
thrown away this shouldn't leak but
that's a nice little check we can do and
i just wrote one of those for each
you'll notice uh some of the definitions
i went ahead and moved into
the cpp vial but not all of them some of
them had to be like these equip and use
functions it was having some strange
errors something i was doing here so
they had to move to the cpp but i hadn't
moved all of them yet but essentially
these functions are all the same it's
just the cast is different
uh in all of them so we also
so yeah we have we built all those his
item of whatever and you can pass it any
item and it'll return true or false
that's going to help us later when we're
moving stuff around
and it's going to give us some some
quick functions to be able to tell what
things are
all right and now we're going to try the
cast we've also written some cast
functions here so that
well no one's allowed to do these casts
you can't just do these on the fly
throughout your code
because no one has access to this data
except item manager you can get const
version of the data with the get data
function in our item let's go take a
look at that
back to item here
find get data there it is so in the item
yeah we have
a const version of returning the data
but no one can edit that and you can't
cast it since it's const actually you
might be able to cast it let me check
something here
if we go
weapon
star
i think if it's boxed you might actually
be able to
let's just check equals
uh what is this a
magic
weapon cast it to a const
weapon pointer like this needs to be
dynamic cast
type in the wrong thing
and this here should be
a magic
weapon
uh get data
so yeah you you can freely cast it to a
const
one
i actually didn't think of this before
but yeah
you just can't cast it to a mutatable
one like so it's going to complain and
say it doesn't handle costs we kind of
ran into that earlier but you can
actually get around it by just doing
const here
but the reality is we don't want people
messing with these if they're
this is actually okay because well if
they want to manage their own pointer
but if the weapon if this magic weapon
gets deleted this becomes a dangling
reference and if you try to do stuff
with it it's going to crash so you got
to be more careful so that's that's a
thing to keep in mind but you can
do that and we could just fully get rid
of this get data so that no one could
mess with it and that's kind of as
intended and that way they have to use
the item manager function and in fact
we'll do that i'm just going to comment
it out for now
there's some things commented out
we might we'll delete them later but
really we want this item manager to
handle everything about the memory as
much as possible
that way we don't have memory leaks if
we get people playing around with it
that are using the library the more
freedom we give people the more likely
they are to mess things up if they don't
really understand what's going on behind
the scenes and if they're using the
library typically you don't want people
to have to understand what's going on
behind behind the scenes you want your
interface to be clear and not leak
memory basically
and do what it's supposed to do all
right so let's continue uh
all right so we make
at this point we make a weapon pointer
and a weapon of course is an item
delegate but it is not
an item let me go back to item here
if you remember correctly this item
doesn't inherit from anything it's its
own class it's just got the item
delegate data inside of it
so yeah the weapon here is not actually
an item which i know it sounds a little
backwards but
it's just the way we're doing things to
be able to tell what type of item it is
all right so now we got this cast item
to weapon
and this way we can get a mutatable
version of it this will allow us to take
this
well let's look at this function here
and what it does this is rather
important
so this cast item to weapon takes
the item pointer and it takes
a weapon pointer
that probably should be null but it
doesn't actually have to and here's the
function cast item to weapon
so if we look at this
it takes a cons item pointer in this is
the input it's cost because it doesn't
we don't want to change it and then it
takes a weapon pointer reference out now
this is something that we haven't
covered before
a pointer reference wait this this was
confusing to me for a long time so
imagine it is to a lot of other people
too isn't a reference already a pointer
why a pointer reference when do you use
a pointer reference let's talk about
this okay so
if we take off the reference it's no
longer this pointer being passed in
it is a copy of this pointer it makes a
copy if it's not a reference remember
that this right here this n
it's a copy of the i pointer it is
making a new pointer and it's making a
new pointer to out well if it's a copy
to out then this is its own pointer we
want it to be the action we want it to
actually be this one because it's an
output but if you do this
it uh
it makes a copy
of this pointer and sure it sets it to
whatever
but then this one that we passed in it
doesn't do anything with it because this
just this pointer just gets deleted at
the end of this function so this doesn't
actually work what you need is a
reference to that pointer
that way it doesn't copy it
hope that makes sense but that's the
reason and that's when you use reference
is when you want the actual variable you
don't want a copy of it and it's usually
when you're modifying that particular
variable and being that it's an output
and not a return value over here
that's why
so yeah we could do it in a way where
where we return but i personally like
this way better just i think it's clear
enough and all it does here is make a
dynamic cast
of the items data uh
to see if it succeeds and it says out
will be null pointer if the cast fails
and yeah that's the case so
we should do a check so we do this cast
and then we make sure it's not null and
then we can start checking things
so that's actually quite fine
and now that we no longer have that
the get data function we have to use
that
let's continue this but we'll write it
another way just for sake of example
this whole const to get data thing is is
really uh making me think about other
options like maybe we should just allow
it and we could we could entirely get
rid of this but it is kind of nice to
have a clear function
that does it uh however
yeah it's just not a const one so they
could just edit it but you know that's
fine if someone's making an rpg system
and making their game out of this
library they should be able to edit the
items if they want to that should be
under their control
because maybe there are enchantments and
stuff so i think that makes sense to
give them a way to do that
maybe we just want to const way as as
well i don't know it's up for debate all
right let's continue on so yeah we check
and make sure the cast didn't fail
and then we just checked that all its
stats are as we created it up here
basically so it should have all this
stuff and we just check that make sure
that its name is magic weapon like we
set it make sure all the stats are five
as we set them i'll make sure the slot
is melee as we set it and of course we
have to cast all the stuff to end and
that's because of how this testing
library is made it doesn't understand
every data type but it does work pretty
well with integers and they just have
templates and overloads to handle
different types in this testing library
and maybe they need to expand a little
more because like uh
this just turns into what an unsigned i
don't know whatever it turns into but it
doesn't like it even though they're the
same type so
it has a a little trouble with certain
types so that's why we have to do a lot
of int casting
it isn't exactly my favorite thing to do
but it works fine it's not going to hurt
anything all right and then we check the
men damage and the max damage make sure
they're what we set them to make sure
that is two-handed is set as we put it
and now here comes another interesting
part that we really have to think about
so what happens when you delete a magic
weapon
now we probably want a function for this
in the in the long run because we don't
want people to do it on the fly because
what if someone has this in their
backpack or equipped and then it gets
deleted what happens then
a bit of an edge case there and we
probably want to handle that through
functions and we probably want to
disallow this delete but for now we're
going to allow it so if you delete
this original item up here it's going to
call the items destructor
which is
this right here essentially
of course it's going to delete all the
data but anything that has a pointer we
need to make sure it also deletes that
and we do so it ends up deleting the
item delegate
so thus this cast that we did earlier
is now pointing to data that is
incorrect if you reference the data now
you're going to get bizarre values of
just whatever happens to be in that
memory so it's not going to be correct
so you need to set that to null pointer
as well otherwise it is a dangling
reference you cannot call
delete
on
the weapon pointer
because well it's handled elsewhere and
you're deleting the dangling reference
it's not going to know what the heck to
do it's just going to crash basically
but you want to make sure that it gets
sorted out back to null pointer because
otherwise it won't be null
and it also won't be right so you got to
make sure to clean up your dangling
references that's what this would be
here at this point of dangling reference
and then we can assert that it's null as
well and basically we can do the same
thing for these other items the armor
same thing potions same thing
essentially going through the same
functionality just testing that
everything's correct checking that these
casts of the uh his item
are correct
now these are the mutable
these are mutable
cast though what we should also put in
here
is changing stuff and then see if the
changes are correct and we should
probably also write
yeah you know
we should probably all thinking about
this a little bit we should probably
also write ways to handle this delete
better because we don't necessarily want
whoever's using the library to have to
call this delete
and then they would essentially have to
call on whatever character has it they
would have to call that character's
cleanup backpack method and that's
something we're going to have to
refactor for sure so let's look at
player character real quick player
character here it is
let's just look up clean up backpack
here it is it's a private method only
the item manager has access to it the
only place we actually call it currently
is
on the use on this use function
which is down its own cpp file oh we got
rid of this didn't we
all right so we're gonna have to think
about this get data since we got rid of
it
uh but you know we don't necessarily
sh
we can we will put it back for now it's
not gonna hurt anything it is cons not
like anyone can hurt anything with it
unless they do a const cast so just
don't do const cast
yeah
just too dangerous
all right but the yeah the only place we
call clean up backpack is when a usable
potion
uh is quantity of zero then we mark for
deletion called clean a backpack which
does well basically does the delete
stuff with its special stable partition
removed to remove from the vector what
happens if they have an item
in the backpack and you just call delete
like this
don't that's gonna break stuff we're
gonna have strange null pointer
references so we need to come up with a
way to better handle
deleting these items and these mutable
casts this mutable cast is okay really
because like i said the end users should
have the power to change items because
maybe they want to have enchantments and
stuff in their game and maybe they want
to say hey you can give your
item plus strength or whatever if you do
some certain thing in your game
so that's fine
but you know giving them the power
to just delete the the item now that's a
problem so what we're going to end up
doing
is we're going to take this here
and make it private and it has friend
class item manager so only the item
manager will be able to delete it and
then
when we delete it
well that's when we're gonna have to
we're gonna have to make another
function for that to delete it wherever
it's also located so
whatever our deleter function
ends up being so we're basically going
to have something like
static bool
delete item
we'll have an item pointer item to
delete and then we also need to know
where does this exist and what
and what player character is holding
this or what
maybe we even pass it the backpack
itself because
in theory if you have items out in your
world they've got to be in something
that could be
uh in a chest in some kind of pouch in
your backpack
um
you know they've got to be somewhere
but we've been kind of going god mode
and just instantiating them globally so
we probably want to think about how
we're doing that because we don't
necessarily want to be god mode and all
these items in the long run
it's going to be you know it's going to
require a lot of manual cleanup like
this
which we want to kind of happen more
automatically so
pack to delete from we probably want to
do something like this
and if we have this sort of function
we would pass it well
this is going to make a copy of the
vector of item pointers which since it's
a vector of pointers it's going to be
pretty small but we could essentially
delete it and if we don't want you know
we could make a reference here if we
want to pass the actual
vector of items
so now this would be required that if
you're deleting an item you also have to
have a pack that is deleting from which
is going to assume that every item you
make is in some sort of pack
which also means if we're ever creating
armor or items of any sort it assumes
they're going to be in some sort of pack
and if we're calling move to backpack
we're going to assume they're coming
from
some pack
or backpack or chest or or something or
maybe even we'll have like a of
a world just out in the world type chest
you know maybe god rather than god mode
we just have uh like loose items but we
still need to
to manage those carefully
so that's probably going to be the next
step is just cleaning up some of how
these items work just a little bit more
so that we can manage them just a little
bit better and basically avoid having to
do this so that that is going to be the
next step
we are going to comment this out for now
and save that for next episode because
we still have a lot of work to do with
the tests
and now we get to the classes i've only
got the warrior class in here uh oh
pretty neat thing here you can see this
delete is no longer allowed and that is
because
we made it private
so only the the friend class item
manager here is allowed to do it we're
actually going to make this
vinyl as well so we don't want anybody
over
uh
inheriting from item so it's a final
thing
all right
so
for now let's go ahead and have a delete
item
and sure we want this pack to delete
from
but not yet
for now let's go ahead and make this
function and i think if i hit the hotkey
wait let's see
create
definition oh it doesn't it doesn't
understand it so i'm just going to copy
all this go to our item manager down
here
go to the bottom and just paste it in
here don't static on this one
it's in the item manager class and we'll
we'll fix up this function as needed
but basically all this wants to do is
take that item to delete and it's just
going to call delete on it
like so
and now if we think about this
we also want this to be a reference to
the pointer so that we can set it to
null in this way
i guess it would be you know free item
delete item whatever you want to call it
we could just go in here
uh
you know if
we don't want people we want them to be
able to call either version you can do
stuff like uh define
free
item
as delete right
now this has a bull i guess this would
be void
so we could do that and they could call
it either way i don't know if that's
going to work properly in a class
actually let's let's do a little test
here so
let's comment that out for a second and
just go
free item a magic
weapon
oh i guess we gotta go
uh item manager free item
there we go
sure you could write the function twice
or you could just do this to say hey if
they say free item they mean delete item
it's kind of a
a shady thing to do like that honestly
but
a lot of times people just call this
free
rather than delete
so that's why i want to say you could do
that that's just an fyi we're not
actually going to do that but we might
rename this to free later
i don't know it's just something we got
to decide but for now we're going to
make sure that you don't have to call
delete like that
rather do it in this way
we do still have to clean up this
dangling reference now naturally at the
end of this function this reference
would go out of scope so it's actually
okay
uh in this case to just do this
sort of thing
uh
because yeah this is going out of scope
we already deleted its core data no one
else is using it but just something to
be aware of with those dangling
pointers so let's go ahead and clean up
the rest of this rather than delete
we're going to call item
manager
delete item and let it handle it
internally this way if we need to do
other special stuff later to this delete
we can just change it in this function
rather than
anywhere else okay we need a reference
there it's important because we want to
actually be able to set this
item to null pointer and yeah stangling
reference is
going out of scope at the end there
anyway and that check it this check is
redundant because
any pointer you set to null pointer is
is going to be null it doesn't it's not
really a this isn't a good test anyway
here at the bottom it's kind of my point
hope that makes sense
let me know if you have questions
i'm having fun you guys having fun this
is my pride and joy right here
breaking the rules making protected
virtual
destructors yeah
all right well there's a lot of work to
be done still we still need to test
equip and use but uh i'm probably gonna
do that i might do a stream or something
later today of writing all those but i
don't think i'm going to make an episode
of that basically we're essentially
going to be doing the same thing i've
just gone through every function and
writing a test for it it needs to be
done there's really no getting around
the fact that it needs to be done uh so
yeah i'll probably just stream that
later today
um
which might be your tomorrow now i'll
release this episode and then i'll go
live i think that's how it's i'm just
going to do it and that way if people
want to pop in and ask questions about
the series or anything that's fine too
but yeah i think we're pretty much
done for now i've explained everything i
need to explain i'll push this code what
is this complaining about incompatible
okay this needs to be void
all right let's go ahead and run the
code run the test i'm going to hit ctrl
r t
brings up the test explorer that's just
the hotkey here
uh test explorer as you can see but uh
we have a bill there let's address our
build errors show output
let's run our build cannot access
private item it's okay so we have
somewhere else what we're calling delete
and that's right here
so instead we need to call
item manager delete item
pi
all right very good
so this should actually be a reference
as well
and uh let's see if that's happy let's
go ahead and build it
okay we're doing some other deletes okay
so here in uh delete
class we're cleaning up some items the
equipped items it's going to be
essentially the same thing let's just
copy this for a second
so we essentially need to make sure we
delete it like so
using our item manager so this is good
this just means we don't have varying
methods of deleting and cleaning up all
over our code which is
definitely a good thing
and one more build after making those
changes
looks good let's run our tests hit the
run all test button or control r then v
and let's just assert that all these
pass and they do it passes all the tests
looks like we're doing pretty well
everything seems to be working as
intended and we will be building those
rest the rest of those later today hope
to see you there thanks for tuning in
keep coding peace out guys
[Music]
you